PES
[Müzik]
2013 yılında
Biz neyde Magic Kingdom farkında Orlando
da florida'da bir iş fırsatım oldu orada
kesmem olarak çalışmıştım ve
biliyorsunuz dünyanın en mutlu yeri
olarak bahsederler Disney eden birçok da
anı biriktirme şansım oldu orada evlilik
teklifi
benim kendi çalışmam dışında bazı yaptım
aile seyahatleri bütün bunları
yaşadıktan sonra da aslında geriye dönüp
baktığım zaman Özellikle de çalıştığım
dönemde aklıma gelen bazı şeylerden
bahsetmek istiyorum bir isim Bu arada
çalışmaya devam ederken her gün uzun
uzun teşekkür mektupları gelirdi şirkete
Bunlar farklı farklı konulardan de bazen
ertesi gün Afganistan'a askere gidecek
olan babasıyla geçirilen son günlerde
alakalı bazen
engelli ablasıyla geçirilen bir günde
ona gösterilen Özen ile ilgili alakalı
bazen de yeni Şanlı insanlara ısmarlayan
tatlı alakalı böyle sürekli teşekkür
mektupları gelirdi Bende çok ilgimi
çekerdi bu ve bunun neden olduğunu
düşünürdüm Çünkü biz de zaten
çalışanlar olarak buraya bir maaş için
çoğunlukla
başlamamıştı Biz de zaten daha farklı
bir duyguyla daha farklı sebeplerle
başvuru yapmıştık Onlar daha çok böyle
Güven güvenlik kapsayıcılık Hatta
memnuniyet gibi Nezaket gibi konulardan
kaynaklanan sebepler D
bir tanem bu
ve bütün Bunların aslında bir adı var o
da sosyal etki Yani bütün adı konmayan
duyguların anlamı hepimizin üzerinde
bıraktığı bir şirketin ürün veya hizmeti
sebebiyle üzerimizde bıraktığı etkiler
bazen pozitif olabilir bazen negatif
olabiliyor ve sosyal etkilediğini şey
nedir tam olarak sosyal etki herhangi
bir aksiyonun bir şirketin ürünü
tarafından olabilir Bir şirketin
operasyonları sebebiyle olabilir o günü
hazırlarken veya hizmeti bu aksiyonların
toplum ve çevre üzerinde bıraktığı
etkiler
her şirket için geçerli büyük şirketler
için küçük şirketler için Fakat bunların
bazen farkındayız bazen değiliz Hem biz
hem de şirketler zaten farkında
olmayabiliyor zaman zaman bunu bir örnek
vermek gerekirse mesela sosyal medya
Hepimiz bir çoğunuz kullanıyoruz sosyal
medya şirketlerinde o kadar platformda
yapılan bir paylaşım Örneğin
politikacıları birbirine sokuyor veya
bir paylaşım yapılıyor bir anda borsa
yükseliyor Bütün bunlar aslında hepiniz
üzerinde etkisi olan kollar yani
ekonomik olarak duygusal olarak birçok
açıdan üzerine etkisi oluyorlar negatif
olur bozuk olabilir aynı zamanda o
Platformu hepimiz hakkında birileri
vardı bunları saklıyorlar ve bunun
içinde bir enerji sarf ediyorlar Bir
karbon salınımı yapıyorlar bu karbon
salınımları daha çevre üzerinde bir etki
Yani bütün bunlar bir sosyal etki diye
düşünebiliriz
Peki bu sosyal etkiler sadece Disney
veya sosyal medya platformları için de
geçerli Hayır be sosyal etkiler
Özellikle de mesela eğitim platformları
için geçerli işe yerleştirme programları
için geçerli noktada sizdensize
başlangıç noktası akademi'den bahsetmek
istiyorum
bu başlangıç noktası the far kez
Eczacıbaşı liderliğinde kurulan
sürdürülebilirlik konularına teknoloji
konularına önemseyen girişimci ruhlu
insanların bir çok da gönüllünün
birlikte yürüttüğü bir Deneysel bir
topluluk Aslında böyle bir platform ve
biz bir eğitim başlattık ismini Akademi
dedik bu akademide
bu resimden Aslında o akademi'den
çevrimiçi bir eğitim programıdır bu ve
bu eğitim programında bir çok farklı
sosyo ekonomik anlamda birçok farklı
lokasyon anlamında insanı bulduk Türkiye
çapında bine yakın mülakat
gerçekleştirdik ve bunları seçtik
hepsinin ortak özelliği çok yetenekler
ve bu
eğitimlere eğitimleri yaparken bizdede
ki bunlar ücretsiz olsun fırsat eşitliği
sağlayalım
ve biz bu Ama bu eğitimi alırken bu
insanlar sadece eğitimi aldı almadı
Altay boyuyorum eğitim alacaklar mı
almayacaklar mı değil ki aldılar
biz aynı zamanda onlara nasıl bir sınıf
atlatabiliriz hakikaten onları
düşünüyorduk yani Düşünsel olarak
ve ekonomik olarak network olarak birçok
farklı açıdan onları bir yerden bir yere
getirmek Bizim amacımız da bunun için
sektör liderleri ile görüştüler bir sürü
eğitim alarak Ran öğrenmesi yapılar
mentorluk aldılar ve birçok konuda koy
belli eğitimler aldılar ve sonra saçları
yerleştiler
bu stajlarda çok önde gelen yerlerden
girişimler çok güzel girişimler birçok
farklı Kurumsal şirket bütün buralarda
saçları girdiler ve biz burada Hala Ama
şunu bilmiyoruz Gerçekten bu eğitim
programı onları bir yerden bir yere
götürdü mü Çünkü eğitim programları
biliyorsunuz Hepimiz Türkiye'de dün O
çok eğitim programı var bazı ücretli
oluyor bazı ücretsiz online offline baş
rol alan başvurusuz alan bak hangileri
Gerçekten biz bir yerden bir yere
götürüyor bu değişebiliyor bir hepimizde
bunun farkındayız başlar için de geçerli
Bu hangisi gerçekten bizim için gelişim
kaybetmemize sebep oluyor
ve Biz bütün bunlara bakarken dedik ki
Peki bu sadece sosyal medya veya eğlence
parkları veya eğitim programları için
geçerli Hayır sosyal etki ve sosyal etki
ölçme ve raporlaması bütün şirketin en
büyük şirketten en küçük şirkete kadar
herkesin yapması gereken bir şey
çünkü bu hem şirketler için bir finansal
risk oluşturan bir konu hem de bir
avantaj bir fırsat oluşturan bir konu
Peki bu rüzgarın Sebebine birçok farkı
tren var birçok farklı Dünya konuşan
kolu var neler şirketleri daha hesap
verilebilir daha amaçlı ve daha şeffaf
olmaya gidiyor
bunlardan bir tanesi bilinç ve kuşağı
başta olmak üzere giderek toplumda
hassasiyet olabilecek konularda
duyarlılık artıyor hem toplumsal
konularda ve çevresel konularda Yani
herhangi bir şekilde şirket içinde
yaşanan bir problem ölçü ılık olabilir
bu Başka bir konu olabilir şirket içinde
kalmıyor özellikle iletişim araçlarının
Bu kadar yaygın olduğu bir dönemde ve bu
yaygınlık mesela me to hareketi gibi
birçok harekete sebep olabiliyor ve bu
da şirketler için finansal anlamda bir
kaygı
oluşturabilecek bir konu ikinci konu
regülasyonlar
artık Avrupa Birliği başta olmak üzere
birçok bölgede ve birçok ülkede karar
alıcılar regülasyon kuyucular bu konuyu
önemsiyor ve bu konuda teşvik Ben onları
bu konuda yasalar bu konuda farklı
kararlar alıyorlar yani diyor ki
şirketler artık bütün paydaşlara karşı
sorumlu sadece hissedarlarına karşı
sorumlu değil Ve o paydaşlara karşı
sorumlu ysa onları bu etkilemesi lazım
Çünkü biliyorsun sürdürülebilir kalkınma
amaçları var 2030'a kadar 2050'ye kadar
kurulan bir sürü Hedef var Bunların
gerçekleşmesi için şirketlere çok büyük
büyük düşüyor Ve bunun da hesabını
Aslında şirketlerin ya eksi olarak ya da
artı olarak alması lazım Bu yüzden de
mesela geçtiğimiz haftalarda Hollanda
Mahkemesi bir tane petrol şirketine
2030'a kadar yüzde 45 oranında
salınımlarını karbon salınımlarını
azaltır di mi 3. konu verimlilik konusu
zaten şirketler kısıtlı sayıda çalışan
ve sermaye sahip bunları en Optimize bir
şekilde kullanmaya çalışıyor ki
yatırımlarında projelerini ürün ve
hizmetler bu aşağıda olsunlar yani
birçok fizibilite çalışmaları yapılıyor
birçok hesaplamalar yapılıyor veriler
toplanıyor hep birlikte konuşuluyor
vesaire Fakat bunun sosyal etki tarafı
birazcık şu anda kadar en azından arkada
kalmıştı Halbuki sosyal etki de her
finansal açıdan hem de birçok diğer
açıdan bu tip verilerin toplanıp analiz
edilmesi gereken bir konu mu o yüzden
verimlilik anlamında yapılan projelerin
gerçekten onlara avantaj veya finansal
olarak ne zaman taş sağlayacağını veya
sağlamayacağını bilmeleri anlamında
yapılacak yatırımlarda sosyal etki Ama
üzerinde yapılması kaynakları doğru yere
doğru şekilde aktarılması çok önemli ve
son olarak da Phone on artık etki
fonları başta olmak üzere birçok fon var
ve girişimlere özellikle de toplumsal
fayda ile finansal getirip bir araya
getiren Yani bir yandan topluma çevresel
anlamda veya toplumsal anlamda katkıda
bulunur ama bir yandan da para kazanan
şirketlere fon yağıyor bunlardan bir
tanesi mesela geçtiğimiz haftalarda bir
elektrikli araç şirketi 110 milyon dolar
yatırım aldı başka bir tane tedarik
zinciri girişimi şeffaflık sağladığı
için 43 milyon dolar yatırım aldı
Peki bütün bunlara baktığımız zaman
küçük şirketten büyük şirkete bütün bu
trendlere de analiz ettiğimiz zaman
Neden peki o zaman şu anda bu kadar
fazla yapılmıyor şirketlerde bu sosyal
etki ölçüleri ve raporlamaları birincisi
hep bir kere büyük şirketlerde küçük
şirketlerde lerde farklı farklı sebepler
var Bunlar bazen maddi güçlük bazen
yetkinlik eksikliği Yani bunu yapacak
insan yok bilmiyorlar ya da biliyorlar
fakat bunu yeterince zaman ayırmak
istemiyorlar Çünkü yeterince büyük bir
kadroları yok bütün bunlara baktığımız
zaman Aslında bu işin Demokraside edin O
dediğin hem bilgi anlamında hem de maddi
anlamda maliyet anlamında demokrasisi
edilmiş edilmesi gerektiğini gördük ve
bunun için bir platform oluşturduk minik
onun aklında adında bir platforma
birlikte esp'nin yani encg nedir Çevre
sosyal yönetişim bu alanların tamamında
hem şirketlerin ürünleri hem de
operasyonları Bu ürünler üretirken
yaptığı çalışmalar anlamında topluma ve
çevreye
etkilerini ölçebileceğimiz teknolojik
bir araç oluşturduk Yani bu iş otomatik
ettik aslında dedi ki siz veririz gelin
biz bütün Oha bu koyacağız sonra da
zaten ortaya çıkacak etkiniz ve bunda
raporlamak için hazır bir şekilde
edeceğiz
Bunu sadece biz yapmadık üstüne
uyguluyoruz zaten başlangıç noktasına
başka yerler der ve bunu yaptıktan sonra
da biz dedi kim Tamam bu güzel fakat Ne
gibi metrikleri mesela bakacağız Örneğin
başlangıç noktasına bakarsak Evet şimdi
Bağcılar'a giriş girdiler bahsettim
50'ye yakın kişi seçmişti bunlar
stajlara girdiler Peki stajlarda biz
şuna bakmak yeterli olduğunu düşünüyoruz
staja girdim girmedim veya o staj da
işte kaldı mı yoksa çıktı mı yarısında
Bunlar yeterli değil bizim başarılı
olduğumuzu veya olmadığını anlamamız
için Çünkü biz yaptık bu eğitim
programını biz aldık bu insanları ve
onların hayatında belli bir hakikaten
dönüşüm istiyorsak bunu gözlemleme mi
lazım O yüzden dedik ki biz sadece
bunlara bakmıyorsun hakikaten sosyal
etki ölçümlemesi yapalım nelere bakalım
Peki bu girdi staja bu kişi Ama maaş
olarak Pazar ortalamasına göre daha mı
Yukarıdaki maaş alıyor da mı aşağıda
maaş alıyor part-time ve çalışıyor
sultanı çalışıyor sağlık ve güvenlik
riskleri minimize edilmiş mi edilmemiş
mi bu veya bilgi anlamında akımına katkı
sunan bir şeyler alıyor mu o fotokopi
mesela çekiyor
veya bütün bunları yaparken daha önceden
belli bir deneyimi varsa belli bir yerde
çalışmıştı oradaki aldım Ayşegül şimdi
Daha yukarıda alıyordu ama aşağıda
alıyor bütün böyle Aslında birçok
Messi'ye bakıyoruz onlarca metrik var ve
bu iki teker bize Aslında Resmin gerçek
yüzünü gösteriyor fakat bunu da beraber
burada getirmiyoruz Diyoruz ki
finansal bilançolar bu kadar şeffaf Çok
uzun zamandır bir şekilde yayınlanıyor
burada parasal cinsle kâr zararlar
çıkıyor vesaire değil mi şimdi sosyal
etkiyi de aslında giderek finansal
iğrenç olar gibi sosyal etki bilançoları
olarak yayınladığımız gerekiyor ve bu
ikisini birleştiriyoruz gerekiyor çünkü
bu ikisi birleştiği zaman ancak o zaman
bir şirketin gerçekten Başarılı mı bilme
olduğunu daha iyi tanımlayabiliriz şu
anda bir şirket başarılı mı Baş Sağ ol
diye sadece kara kazandığı paralarla
Aslında hesaplanıyor ve o şekilde
hepimiz biliyoruz yani şu kadar kar
yapıyor bu kadar değerlemesi var filan
Fakat bu Karlar Bu değerlemeler tamamen
kazanılan Parayla alakalı halbuki bu
işin bir de toplumsal tarafı var Bu
yüzden bu başarı tanımını birazcık
genişletelim dedik ve bu bilançoları bir
araya getirelim bunu nasıl yapacağız
peki 50 kişi mesela girdi staj ayı Ama
bunlar 50 kişi girdi olarak metrik bu
parasal cinsi Yok hiç orada para sadece
Savunun hesaplama yöntemleri var çevirme
yöntemleri var Çünkü bunu zaten biz
oluşturuyoruz mesela biz uluslararası
birçok meteoroloji inceliyoruz bunlardan
bir tanesi Harvard Business school'da
Joker Selam diye bir kişinin liderlik
ettiği muhasebe muhasebesel hesaplama
yöntemi mi Ne yapıyoruz mesela 50 kişi
bizden ücretsiz bir eğitim aldığı zaman
pazarda bunun alternatif ne diyecek
miydi Tamam diyelim ki bulabilecek bin
liraya ama alabilecekti biz ücretsiz
sağladığımız için bunu Aslında 50.000
liralık bir ortaya görünmeyen Normal
şartlarda bizim kâr ve zarar ımıza
çıkmayan bir finansal değer oluşturmuş
olduk bu tip böyle hem STK ların hem
şirketin herkesin yapması gerek bu
hesabı ya eğer ki biz mesela ücretsiz
ile 2000 lira yapıyor olsaydı pazarda
bin lira erken Bu sefer de eksi 50 bin
lira alacaktı bizim için bu yani bu işin
toplumsal tarafı bir yana bir anlamda
oluşturulan finansal diğerini Tıpkı
şeker zarar gibi eksi şu kadar artık bu
kadar gibi parasal cidden yazılması
lazım parasal olarak şu kadar kâr
etmişsinizdir sosyal etki anlamda bu
kadar kâr veya zarar etmişsinizdir
bunları da bir araya getirdiğiniz zaman
biz Aslında gerçekten karım ediyorsun
zarar mı orada çıkar meselâ bazı
Havayolları Belki de zarar ediyor bu
kadar çevresel atıkları Halbuki biz
onları yıllardır çok yüksek değerlerle
biliyoruz bu
ve sonuç olarak biz aslında
burada bütün büyük şirketleri bütün
küçük şirketleri bunu
kabul edip bunu yüzleşmeye ve bunu
finansal fırsat veya Risk olarak görüp
bunu uygulamaya yani ölçümü ve raporlama
yapmaya çağırıyoruz ne demek bu Eğer ki
bir şirket müşteri sayısını artırmak
satışlarını artırmak istiyorsa işte
görüyorsunuz sürekli şu şirketler daha
temiz şirketlerdir gibi böyle beyaz
hisseler çıkıyor Artık sosyal medyalarda
işte yaptığı çalışmalarla alakalı
vesaire Eğer ki satışların yükseltmek
istiyorsan eğer daha fazla yatırım almak
istiyorsan eğer ki inovasyonu veya
verimliliği artırmak istiyorsa
çalışanların motivasyonunu artırmak
istiyorsan çalışanların motivasyonlarını
bunlarla çok artıyor biz bunları
anketleri yaptık
veya regülasyon olarak kendini korumak
istiyorlarsa 21l çık abi Bu bir İster'e
Karşıya da şirkette olabilecek negatif
hiç Beklenmeyen bir durumun onları
finansal açıdan bir zarar vermesi bütün
bunları düşünerek bunları önlemek veya
yaratmak için fırsat anlamında da biz
bunları yapıyoruz herkes de bunu yapmaya
çağırıyoruz Çok teşekkürler